à québec il suffit aussi on voit trois
aujourd'hui comme une allée voir si le
souffle
les trois wagons premier chaînon que mon
gars alors on a une bonne nouvelle on a
trouvé le château pour le mariage
d'ailleurs tu vas compagne et moi je
viendrai avec que ces classes tomber sa
colocataire oui mais c'est si ses mains
c'est ma meilleure amie
mais simone mais l'achat pas toujours
bien quand tu sera prête c'est tout et
je suis prête
le problème c'est pas moi on s'est eu
oui je sais je sais je suis une mauvaise
mère
je suis ni lui ni lui ni moi c'est bien
qu'on fait là ses plaisirs
[Musique]
plane ou n'importe quoi c'était beau et
on va un peu vite toi on va chez moi
hier tu nous entends mariage aujourd'hui
tu couches avec un mec qui sont ma
gueule quoi t'en met justement en
attaque ça compte pas
plus tôt après tout qui ça fait mal
envie d'un mec et toute l'étape et c'est
de là qu'est ce que tu fais là et
quelques mamans quatre usines
c'est ma vie privée je vais vous les
vidéos
ces derniers temps j'étais perdue sans
toi
molina ne m'avait pas puisque une belle
fille est mariée
il est à rome et si deux car tu ferais
quoi c'est pas du tout ce que vous
pensez j'ai déconné je sais que j'ai
découvert
[Musique]